la nouvelle biographie qui sort sur le
couple à l'idée et il ya aussi une bombe
qui a été lancé la ballade de johnny et
laeticia donc du journaliste de paris
match
benjamin locoge et on y apprend quelques
anecdotes à commencer par la jalousie de
laëtitia de la relation johnny catherine
deneuve
voilà alors déjà il faut savoir que
johnny catherine deneuve se sont
rencontrés sur un tournage d'un film
lorsque johnny avait 20 ans il est tombé
fou amoureux de la jeune actrice c'est
d'ailleurs sur ce tournage que johnny
interprétera retiens la nuit
pour catherine deneuve reims et saint
michel chanson de charles aznavour
il était fou amoureux d'elle amour
impossible puisqu'elle était déjà en
main
catherine ben moi je vous parlais voilà
et voyons cet amour mourir jody décide
de commettre l'impensable et il a fait
une tentative de suicide
voilà je vous le dis il raconte ça dans
son autobiographie il ne restait plus
qu'à mourir au volant de ma trion j'ai
bloqué le compteur sur l'autoroute de
l'ouest au moment où j'allais lâcher mes
mains du volant et rejoindre jimmy dean
en enfer panne d'essence
incroyable mais vrai sans ça veut pas ça
veut pas c est non mais c'était cool
c'esr tulsa tutu le savez est en fait
l'actrice et le chanteur aurait continué
à se fréquenter pendant des années
catherine deneuve sur et lady lucy la
maîtresse qui aurai en t le coeur de
johnny hallyday tout au long de sa vie
elle a même inspiré hôtelier une chanson
lady lucile qui figure sur l'album
lorada sortie en 95 et lætitia tomber en
95 sur des facs de cette dite lady
lucile destiné à johnny a été très
énervé
elle a décidé d'organiser donc pour
calmer laeticia johnny a décidé
d'organiser une croisière dans les
caraïbes et catherine deneuve échanges
depuis des années des moutons avec
johnny catherine et johnny s'écrivent
s'envoie des messages
l'autre l'éthicien en prend ombrage et
demande à son homme d'y mettre un terme
deneuve sera désormais absentes de la
vie du rocker c'est vrai cette histoire
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai en revanche
dans le bouquin c'est page 39 jamais
rien eu entre eux bah bah si cette
émission
chaoui combustible est platonique il
écrit et complicité platonique depuis
les années 60 pas platonique du tout ah
oui évidemment il était jeune il était
beau ils ont dû consommer mais c'est pas
grave c'est pas l'essentiel
mais en tout cas c'est vrai qu'ils ont
gardé une relation très pour les 106
jusqu'à la fin en revanche il cache
effectivement les textos qui lui envoyer
parce qu'elle avait comme une manie
laetitia c'est de regarder tous les
portables pas qu'elle est jolie
et celui des copines d'ailleurs il
planque est tout ouïe plan qui tue les
portables oui parce que laetitia elle
regarde et les textos et des uns et des
autres dans le livre que johnny était
aussi jaloux de laëtitia de sa carrière
alors on y découvre également que johnny
n'hésite pas à appeler son ami le
président nicolas sarkozy pour assainir
tant qu'il peut sa situation financière
c'est ce qu'ils disent dans le livre un
manque du côté du cabinet nicolas
sarkozy raconte même ils nous ont
sollicités en permanence pour la cousine
la femme de ménage le visa de la
grand-mère les impôts combien de fois
nicolas sarkozy at il été réveillés en
pleine nuit par un johnny qui
s'inquiétait de ses impôts
ce que michel 3 voilà ta ta ta ta
fréquenté tout le monde tous les hommes
politiques s qui était déjà arrivé de
demander un gros service par exemple à
un homme politique ou pas du tout jamais
non jamais non pas du tout t'as jamais
rien demandé non plus souvent linverse
c'est souvent l'inversé outil doit
devenir sur le canapé par exemple assez
salée les maigres les mecs veulent venir
alors c'est vrai que voilà alors
l'histoire donc de johnny hallyday et
catherine deneuve tout le monde n'a pas
une histoire du cambriolage on aura des
infos lac dont les oui il faut rajouter
quand même c'est un livre donc j'ai bien
lu tout à l'heure qui est vraiment un
livre de fans ouais c'est une belle
chose benjamin visiblement est fan de
johnny on le savait c'est ça qui
attendent beaucoup des choses il tacle
un peu sylvie vartan parfois par exemple
il y révèle un truc que sylvie aurait
dit au départ alors que c'est pas
vraiment le style de sylvie que c'est
pas boucle d'or laëtitia mais c'est
plutôt margaret thatcher wade donne des
détails sais pas pourquoi ils attaquent
les deux trois fois sylvie vartan bons
d'autres moins salive de fans qui est
bien écrit qui est très intéressant on
n'a pas pas grand chose d'exceptionnel
il faut quand même le dire parce que tu
sais tout mais moi j'ai appris et non
ils savent après quoi pour la fidélité
vous savez on s'en doutait mais je ne
savais pas mais en tout cas il ya des
noms il ya des dates etc
et puis on apprend surtout que les ti ça
n'est pas la sorcière que tout le monde
est plein ils restent amis comme dit
quelques vérités qu'elle a quand même
tenté de multiples fois déciderez
consignes et le clan même si à la fin
c'était la blessure était trop profonde
pour le bruit et réussir mais quand même
ça rétabli un peu les choses sur
notamment laura qui n'était pas aussi
présente que peut-être son johnny ou le
leti salle avait suggéré en tout cas et
des rebondissements tous les jours